this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised
good afternoon good afternoon and a very
warm welcome to all of you ladies and
gentlemen are they watching us on this
beautiful Sunday afternoon my name is
Steve Faulconbridge I'm joined by Craig
on camera and this is Safari live and we
were out in the wilderness in the sabi
sands jhummer private game reserve South
Africa please feel free to Cynthia
questions hashtag Safari Live follow us
on YouTube stream Medus know what you'd
like to see the temperature today is 29
degrees Celsius 85 degrees Fahrenheit it
is blustery windy afternoon and we are
going to go find ourselves some lions so
jump on board and buckle up your seat
belts bring a jacket like a little cold
later I hope everyone's had a wonderful
day I had a last morning off muscles
even while the others did all their work
so now it is my favorite hopefully we
will manage to find this morning and
there's always should they so it begins
Oh welcome welcome unfortunate seems
like Steve he's not getting off to the
best start with the gremlins my name is
Brent Leo Smith I have the incredible
veer maker of all the beasts on camera
and you can see I'm staring at the sand
and I'm staring at the sand to try to
find you a leopard so we have a report
that she drew the female leopard crossed
after Drive in this area however it's
the same spot where the in Colma pride
costs lots of tracks all over the place
so I'm just trying to decipher what's
going on remember this is a hundred
percent live and we do apologize for the
technical difficulties bringing you wild
Africa live from South Africa can be a
little bit troublesome sometimes but
hopefully our incredible tech team will
have it sorted in no problem okay now if
I see if we can find where this female
leopard crossed otherwise if we don't
see any tracks this is of quite a busy
road we'll head down towards treehouse
so it's a good spot to look for leopards
and they say quite a lot of Lion tracks
from where them corners came in this
morning
and of course it is didn't need to draw
a bird day so if you have drawn any
birds please take a picture tweet them
with the hashtag Safari live share them
about pop them on the Safari live
Facebook page and do whatever you need
to do to get that bird to us ok I'm
going to concentrate a little bit more
I'm gonna go see if this leopard had a
drink down here while I do that let's go
see Taylor who draw a very realistic
bird eating an elephant and where's your
bird brained at least I drew drew one my
name is Taylor mccurdy and on camera
with me days since all we were on Bush
walk and that's Herbie he's gonna be
keeping us safe he's also eating an
apple at the moment so it's good to stay
hydrated make sure you have a snack when
you're on a walk now we did have a
wildebeest but unfortunately he's run
away you may remember from the sunrise
Safari we had a wildebeest just start
over there he was standing on termite
mound he's not migrated this way and now
he's running away from us because the
wind is picked up and I think he's a
little bit uncertain about our movements
there but we'll hopefully see him in a
little bit I can see his head popping up
every an hour name now we're gonna be
giving brain to hand on finding that
leopard apparently she do two crossed in
and from arethusa no not a little
gallery so we're gonna get hidden that
direction and see what we can find this
would be quite nice and then we'll also
be stopping sort of for some of the
smaller things as we go along and
because it's draw birthday I've bought
my book art notebook with me so that we
can get Herbie to hopefully draw a bird
for us at some point today so that's
going to be quite exciting so I feel
like II also need to do get in on all
the action and so that is the plan for
us what we're gonna do is you basically
we're gonna just hug quarantine I'm
gonna sort of march south and to get
into the area where well she do do is
hopefully hopefully going to be I don't
get caught on all sorts of vegetation
first so that is the plan maybe some
elephants would be quite nice
now some of you may have seen that
Herbert has got a rifle and it's very
important that we do take a rifle out on
Bush walk so Corley it's it's there for
protection obviously our first point of
Defense's are brain I'm Lindsey we're
both trained and animal behavior and the
idea of a bush walk is not to walk up
and scratch a line between its years
that's not what we're gonna be doing but
it does allow us to be able to view
animals on on foot when we walk we walk
as if we didn't have a rifle but you
well you do have to carry one when you
go out on a walking Safari but the
chances of that having to be used is
very very so that for example I've been
in the bush for just over seven years
and I've never ever had to shoot an
animal or anything like that or even one
or two close calls which is of course
natural when you are walking and walking
and walking and walking otherwise you're
probably not going to need it so don't
worry about that
one of the very favorite things of
brains is of course to do a bit of
trekking and he's wasted no time he's
looking down at the ground
we found she did his tracks coming to
drink at that small pan and then she
went off into the the bushy acid we're
just trying to see if she pops out on
the road and as we slowly head towards
tree house
yeah those lines came down here as well
some of them very popular entrance point
for cats today
shabam red now we're looking for she
Julia it's always wise to put one's eyes
up into the trees and she does like to
rest up high in the trees
more so than our other females
unfortunately we haven't got any tax
aver just yet
lots of Lion tracks up and down around
so as those who were watching the Sun
bumpity-bump sunrise Safari will know
that in Columbus and the torchwood pride
had a slight altercation I watched a
video of it from someone who was who was
there and it wasn't too serious that was
actually pretty as lion fights go it was
pretty meek in my experience it was a
bit of growling a bit of slapping but
nothing nothing too serious at all the
one thing that was quite funny was the
little ink all my mail charged in and
started roaring thinking it was a lot
bigger than he is
so yes sir nothing much hello could are
you going to stand still for long enough
or are you going to run off nice big
adult female could you now
there's a little baby as well behind it
just caught a glimpse of it just see its
ears now it's good to know where could
you are because with this wind it's very
good leopard hunting where that once the
specially once it gets a bit cooler it's
gusting wind going all over the place so
there's a good chance and the leopards
might be up and on the move a little bit
earlier than usual on the hunt and
knowing where the kudu are they are
quite often very good alarm systems and
they're got a very deep loud bark when
they do see a leopard Wow
I'm not seeing any tracks of doo doo
just yet not just looped on chicks
averages track check back up Phil Aman's
and all the Lion tracks here she might
have changed their mind and gone back
towards the northwest
I'm keeping a good lookout in the trees
for a dangling Kitty tail
we spend a lot of time tracking cats and
yes Wolfgang we we we are able to tell
the age of tracks is quite a few
different ways to age tracks a windy day
like today actually tracks it might be a
little fresher than you think the edges
would have been rounded by the wind what
animals or little insects and stuff have
walked across them if there's any
nocturnal animals that have walked
across so yes we are able to to age
tracks and work out which ones are fresh
enough to follow and which ones aren't
now after all the rain we had two days
ago three days ago tracking is a little
bit more difficult because the rain
compounds the ground and makes it quite
a lot harder so an animal as small as a
female leopard often you're just
tracking the slightest little mark so it
can be quite tricky but fortunately we
get lots of practice so we're quite good
at finding them
now I know tailors also heading slowly
into the serious
it's as if they can find she doodle on
foot but it seems that she's been
distracted by a bush on her way no we're
trying to march on and sadly I've been
shaking all the sinners all the wealth
areas their water on the round-leaf teak
and that got me today but no insects I
don't know whether all I can see little
grasshoppers jumping every now and then
but they blend in so well with the
ground then once they've jumped and
they're all here's a bee fly these are
quite cool things I don't know how close
I don't know how close she can see but
basically it's there somewhere I don't
to go too close because I never go too
close
maybe if you want to stand over it I
don't know then you might be able to see
it a bit better but there's a beautiful
bee fly there
they're like fluff balls like cotton
balls was a long proboscis you see if
flies buzzing a partner where you can
land where you can land there we go no
it's yeah and you see it
come here sorry this is always the
hardest partner no I've lost it insects
being difficult today ok now I've lost
it I think it may have flown away
anyways it was quite cool just seeing
more and more of them buzzing around oh
it's quite nice we'll try to get another
one
one that's more cooperative maybe not in
the long grass it's exceptionally windy
today so I feel like a lot of the
insects are gonna struggle to hold on do
anything now this is not great when you
are on a bush walk you don't really want
to do bush walks when it's super super
windy and a lot of times you actually
end up canceling them when you're
walking with guests obviously with us
it's a little bit more different that's
we're in a small group I'm a trained
guide Herbie's at rain garden well since
all's been on and off bush walks to just
about be a trails guide as well so he
knows what to do he's followed all of us
but when you're with guests it becomes a
little bit different you can't hear very
well I'll never hear an elephant feeding
off of a military in this or even a
buffalo as it walks through the leaf
litter I'm not gonna hear a thing and
that's no good also because it's so
windy those animals are going to be on
edge like we saw the wildebeest that's
normally fine with us from the far
distance away on foot he was not having
any of it and even in a big wide-open
area was moving away from a showing that
he was really really uncomfortable with
our presence so we need to be on serious
high alert today and we're gonna try not
walk through any dance areas we're gonna
be using roads a little bit more than
normal and just just sort of well help
us out a bit it's scary not being able
to hear you're out on a bush walk but
we'll make do
I'm just checking as we're walking it I
mean if you notice like when I'm walking
I'm sort of just kicking the ground
seeing if I can chase any insects or
anything up and hope that one will jump
and will I sure able to see where it
lands what's the little here tail
butterflies fluttering about thanks
struggling in the wind today they you
see them go up and then blow away
they're trying to keep up with them as a
nominee see there was grasshopper
goodness that jumped about a meter and a
half there's another bee fly what you
see it says oh it's not sitting down
it's just sort of hovering that's
incredible
the way that it's desperately trying to
not get blown away in the wind but even
the little insects are struggling where
you gonna sit just putting itself Donna
I don't think it's feeding or doing
anything like that I think it's actually
just trying to find a spot to rest to
keep out of the one because it isn't
particularly pleasant but I'm going to
scare it because I want the marula fruit
that's yeah doesn't seem to be too
bothered by me at all
look at this this must be the last my
ruler of the season which is pretty cool
and it's good enough for me to eat sorry
sins oh I'm Jake eat you want it you
don't eat it okay we'll save it for just
now halfway through the walk and I'll
have a little more that's going to be
delicious
no one Hey we can share it okay
Sam's on I may be sharing a marula fruit
if you're gonna head down towards a
Herbie we're gonna go through Philemon
step now so we're almost where we need
to start looking for should you do so
we'll give brain to han soon he is
obviously way ahead of us let's go find
out what road ease on I'm wondering how
sensor and tail are going to share
Marilla food it's quite quite tricky
considering its size and all the flesh
attached to the pub interesting okay so
we we are just double checking again if
she Duty has come up this way and again
looking at all the nice bigger trees and
as we know she likes to nap in trees now
it was just after nine o'clock this
morning that she crossed her she could
have done considerable distance so we
might just check down Zoe's Road quickly
and I still quite warm even though
you've got this very gusty wind today I
mean it's changing direction constantly
not too strong but definitely strong
enough to affect some of the animals
particularly your prey species you'll
find your Impala and and vole beasts
zebra and things like that will be quite
jumpy too in this weather
okay she has been spotted quite a few
times resting and rulers around yeah
that's why we just going a little bit
slower
it's almost sign of attraction you might
even still be inside one of those blocks
behind us
that's where bushwalk comes in very
handy the ability to spend time on foot
looking for leopards in those areas
now I know Tristan and veeram had an
awesome sighting of she duty yesterday
Jason and you were there with them and I
agree it would be great to see her again
today hopefully we are able to find her
not a lot too not too long a time and if
she hasn't eaten she's going to be quite
active now with a strong gusty wind
that's been blowing all day there's even
a possibility she might have managed to
catch herself something during the day
and she's in one of these thick areas
sitting happy with a kill
and a quick look down yes is one of her
seems to be one of our preferred routes
along Zoey's ride
no sign of any tracks we'd see them
quite easily on yet
our tailor found some leopard cub tracks
a few days ago Cristina
there are not catch Ava's cub tracks
Chava does not move into that area
there's no ways she would bring her cub
into that area for multiple reasons like
Tandy would probably kill it
Herkimer you might kill it so it is a
not a safe area and there's no reason
for her to bring her cub into that area
an area she doesn't know and doesn't
frequent so it's almost certainly not
good Chavez cab tracks that Taylor had
oh wow we've been not having many of
these around so that quickly let's go
across to Taylor no we're just moving
around repositioning because look who
we've got there's been much talk about
we have the elephant's gone over the
last few days we found one of them which
was quite nice I suspect it is a bull
but he's just walking down full Aman's
cutline Oh on Joe here we go there's
your elephant there's one of them now
like I said it's very very windy so it's
not really a great day to do approaches
unless unless we are will we stay in the
favour of the one we don't this elephant
to be able to smell us cuz he's gonna
get quite nervous who'll be frustrated
that he can't hear us
that's one of the primary senses that
elephants are relying on is actually
their they hearing as long as their
sense of smell so we don't want to do
that so we'll let them see we might even
just take a gamble and view from a
distance they'll be further away we will
try and get a little bit closer than
this though but as soon as we go through
this drainage line and up on the other
side the environmental factors are all
going to change the wind is going to be
probably blowing a little bit of a
different direction so we'll have to
have a look and I wonder if he got
nervous because that's where the lines
were all walking down the road and
laying on the road and that might make
him a bit nervous too but we'll be
careful right so we're gonna see if we
can sneak a bit closer
off you go to Brent and I promise you
brains will be there
a while
well I think I think that elephants
probably nervous due to the gusting wind
some ellie's just don't really like it
those lines are quite far away from
there now and I'm pretty sure that any
I'll be able to smell that now just a
quick update on Steve and he's returned
to camp and is changing vehicles so
hopefully Wendy will be a little bit
more reliable so you should be out
shortly it's a good spot to look for
kochava we can park up here on the high
ground and I can check with my
binoculars multiple marilla trees and
maybe we'll get lucky and spotted tail
hanging out of one of them
definitely one of my favorite views on
Juma is from this particular section
it's just going to look forward we can
get the whole valley
okay what can we see him yeah so we just
have a quick look you can see nice and
far quite a few trees that would be are
a nice sort of napping spot for a
leopard
you can see how gusty the wind is
unfortunately no sign mm we check next
it's it down towards Philemon step from
Rebecca's Road
now we've been asked this quite a lot in
the last while Laura in almost all a
likelihood shadow has moved on to the
next plane and so has the cub they have
not been seen in over six weeks and
there have been lots of other leopard
seen and what is traditionally shadows
territory named neha koumori and they
could and she do lu as seems to have
taken over the majority of that so I
think unfortunate but the most likely
likely scenario is that shadow has has
been probably killed by another leopard
and with the care for the Cubs sake it's
almost certainly another leopard like
Okumura or shadaloo remember that
leopard cub mortalities said that over
70% of the mortalities are committed by
other leopards not by lions not behind
us so of the known leopard mortalities
nearly 70% committed by other leopards
mostly young males but all males moving
into an area
Wow with women seems to be getting
stronger good thing I didn't win my big
hat today I would have blown off
I said the wind is blowing gusting
actually Cates you the biggest impact of
the wind it doesn't really affect the
ice on safari as much sometimes it can
make certain animals a little bit more
difficult to find and certain animals a
little bit more nervous so in parlor
wildebeest Dyk all your sort of prey
species can be very very jumpy and
birding is quite difficult in the wind
as well the Predators quite enjoy the
winter so they're often mobile the lions
leopards wild dogs a cheetah or all
don't mind the wind the wind is often a
good aid for them in hunting and enables
them to sneak up on those prey species a
little bit more easily that's why they
can be a bit more nervous also animals
like elephant can be a little bit more
nervous during during strong gusty winds
like this
from our point it does make tracking a
little bit more difficult as strong
winds like this can cover up the tracks
blow the edges so that they're harder to
spot but on a positive note
keeps it a little bit cooler
okay well let's go see coast madam
mccurdy is to that Ellie well we're
deciding now what we're going to do
whether we leave this elephant or we do
an approach we can't see him anymore he
walked obviously to the road turned back
and they went into the thicket this was
sort of the last view we had of him but
it's really not nice and here today it's
exceptionally windy so I'm thinking cuz
herby is not 200 percent so I think that
we're probably gonna leave it and maybe
just try and move past him you just see
if we can see him now
see we can't hear normally what would be
easy we could just stand here on the
road and if you've gone into the bushes
we would hear where he was feeding where
is move can't do them today which is a
bit of a nuisance typical windy no it
can't see our elephants we've been
searching for elephants for ages so so
that's the plan for now also we decided
to give the marula fruit to Herbie he
was like a kid in the candy straw he
doesn't he
let's pump the a was so excited that he
got the last one he sends on I'll have
to wait till next yet to get one well
maybe we're lucky maybe we find two more
who knows
so as we're walking along and we gonna
stick to the road because the grass gets
very tall just trying to see through the
gaps the pockets of the big bush willow
trees we can see you this elephant I
mean at any moment he could turn and
come running back in this direction
because he's got a fright ooh he's
picked up a new scent so we're just
gonna be careful basically we were
walking now as to the old hyena den
remember the one all cinnamons Catelyn
now speaking open well potentially being
in dangerous situations with animals
that's a car that I heard and Eloise I
can't see I can you know I've been hit
battered by a few different types of
antelope and I haven't had one on a bush
walk come charging out at me I have
however been rammed by an Impala named
BB that was fun when I was about 14
years old I did this thing at school and
we were in toddlers like a survivor tug
pod and basically read final final count
final counsel is that what they used to
call it on Survivor and they were doing
whoever was going to be voted off and
this Impala rammed me and another girl
that was on top with me it was quite
funny in fact and then when I was really
young and her parents and my parents
friends farm we had this big kudu pool
that drove me around very gently it was
quite funny well my dad always tells the
story and those are the only two times I
don't have survived just checking I hope
you just took a big step in like that so
maybe we'll take a big step in as well
so he was basically coming in this
direction and while you are on bush walk
I'm gonna lower my voice substantially
because the wind is swirling in here
it's not coming from a particular
direction which is a problem I carry
still fine for now but you see how
difficult it is to try and spot him and
it doesn't have much vegetation around
him but even just that little bit
it's just enough to cover the largest
mammal on land he doesn't know we here
and we must be about 100 metres away
from him
hey heard me about 100 metres or so I'm
hoping that we have the wind in our
favor because that's fine because then I
can talk like us and you won't be able
to hear us because he's shaking his head
you can see the way the leaves are
blowing as well blowing off and down
towards the sort of southwest yes herbie
is the champion isn't he
andrew finding animals so the bull is
moving off point tail after him well
just let him go maybe what do you think
the chances are these gonna go to chair
they're pan although mud wallows so I
think what we're gonna try and do is we
think cuz it is a hot day you can see
him just going there it's it's it has
been a very very warm day so we're
thinking maybe he's going to go to the
mud wallows or Pangolin track or perhaps
he is going to go to the wall chilly pan
and if we can try and get there I mean
ideally we'd like to get there before
him but that's fine we'll let him go
first we will just take try and take a
back seat and stick behind him and
hopefully get him but he's still got a
little way to go kilometer or so before
we get to that watering hole but for an
elephant to do that well it's okay okay
we can we keep walking and try and keep
up with that this elephant and since
it's doing an amazing job of walking
backwards I'm pretty sure brains it's
got about 50,000 stories of times that
he's been charged bar antelope
well you're gonna be quiet I mean you've
got to really be trying to think how to
put this nasty it's difficult to get
charged by an answer day is the thing
I'd say I wouldn't apart from doing Game
Capture you don't really get charged by
Angela and VM and I obviously had an
yalla jumped through the window but that
wasn't charging us it was trying to get
away from wild dogs I was in in yalla
jump straight through VIMS passenger
window and ended up on my lap but other
that's apart from Game Capture with semi
sedated animals or animals in capture
nets you don't really get charged by
antelope Archer very very sold them
anyway you need to sort of corner them
in offense whatnot and even a squirrel
can be dangerous if cornered will the
fight or flight mechanisms will take
over and yes
I'm just gonna turn my radio down
okay I'm gonna hit the chick right let's
go see if we can find ten Ghana in the
meantime let's head to Steve who sounds
like he's heading into a similar area to
Taylor
thank you very much Brent I'm terribly
sorry folks for my lack of appearances
so far we've had a few gremlins on the
signal front we have since changed cars
we are in Wendy now and we're out and
about and we have come across the
largest herd of Impala that I've seen in
some time you can see how a lot of them
are very interested in something that's
going on on the left there and what it
is in fact is some warthog running
through the grass but animals are very
unnerved in these conditions and when
it's windy they can't hear the Predators
approaching and many times in the past I
have seen lions and leopards as soon as
the wind picks up like this stand up and
start hunting because the wind obviously
masks their approach and makes it much
easier for them to get closer and so
that's why these animals come together
in such a tight-knit group you think
it's for safety for the others but it's
actually being quite selfish they all
trying to stand in the middle of the
herd and not be on the outside if you're
on the outside or a target and even the
fact that the males are starting to come
into the rutting season you can see
there's not too much concern on their
behavior they were all hanging out
together better to be in a group of this
size than trying to demarcated territory
on your own in these conditions we did
see a male in Pilot boot before we
didn't have signal on his own and he
didn't know what to do with himself he
was jumping up and down and looking in
every direction and the problem is is
when you're constantly on the lookout
and alert you spend very little time
feeding I mean even these guys in this
large group are not feeding very quickly
or a lot because the wind is making them
quite suspicious
not even ruminate see no one's even
ruminating so they're quite ghost I am
on Juma at the moment we are not far
from via Teledyne actually and you want
to know if they are more in parlor there
than on Juma I'm not sure I seems as we
seem to see enormous herds on on Chitra
but then maybe that's just because of
the dam you know we see them coming down
to drink it's quite open there and as
we've seen via tell Adam does not sport
an enormous amount of water at the
moment we're not far from that dam and
I'm sure these are the Impala that spend
their evenings on quarantine the open
area just south of our camp okay that's
one ruminating met Sammy ruminating you
can see they're all a little bit
unsettled if I had to do an alarm call
now I'm sure that all of them would see
me jump up so I'm not going to do that
because that's not very ethical is it
well you can see the boys are in the
middle the boy is in the middle of still
jostling with each other
ghost another Dean parlor a pregnant yet
you can see if we just took in the
frontier of us i Craig it just in the
road you can see a young male in just
here on the right here we go this is a
youngster in the middle of shot you can
see the horns there's a few youngsters
around they were all born in about
November that one that just came in and
a little bit of a head back there he was
born the previous November there he
comes in there's November of last year
and the one just behind him is from
November the year before so you can see
that by the size of the horns but all
the females will get impregnated in the
month of May
April May generally some of them will
come in too late Easter assume that that
mr. mister falling pregnant in the early
season some of them will come back in
August September but none of these are
pregnant yet the rioting season
coming and car will be car starting in
that the coming weeks the the first full
moon in May till the second full moon so
even as early as late April between that
full moon and the next full moon is
generally where all the mating takes
place females come into estrus
stimulated by the males doing their
amazing roaring if you've heard it
before it sounds like something wanting
to come and eat you so there talk about
animals or Impala or antelope attacking
you when you hear that you think
something is coming to finish you off
but it's not the case actually it is the
rori mmm yes yes they can be sneaky out
of racing season but the females are not
in East the East just actually gets
induced bad the roaring that happens
very soon so I think it happens in red
deer as well that they do a lot of
roaring and that stimulates the
ovulation so it's impossible to
impregnate them if they're not ovulating
well that's how it works and we have a
little bit of an Impala road block at
the moment but it's a marvelous to see
so many of them together now we know why
we have such a healthy leopard
population all of this food jostling to
try be in the middle no one really wants
to be on the outside
Macie Impala start growing their horns
from the first few weeks or month of
their birth this one you see there he
was born in November and the horns are
slowly growing and they will grow until
they die in the male's only that is so
they they grow to a certain point
there's lots of interest of these in
pilots to the left I can hear some
Greenwood who is calling and they're not
very relaxed I think we might actually
have a little look around Jake reggae
what do you think but I think it's just
the weather that's spooking them we were
thinking of going in helping Taylor with
her elephants see if we can get the
elephants with the vehicle okay well
let's go over to Taylor who's on foot
and she's got you some tracks well we
just thought we'd stop and have a very
very quick look at this monstrous lion
footprint put my head and thanks to it
and my hand is completely dwarfed next
to it
let me also use both hands today okay so
doing it a bit different here's the back
of the foot yeah and these are the toes
it looks like he was walking quite
quickly and he stood and he slid into
his tracks slightly but that is massive
I mean if I put my hand over there I'm
gonna wreck this track now should we do
it this way that is so cool
virtually my fingers or maybe a
centimeter or two centimetres bigger and
then his track otherwise my hand is
exactly the same width as his footprint
probably his foot just probably a little
bit bigger than that that's crazy
ha so we've had a discussion we've been
trying to figure out who it could be
Tristan said to me they spoke to some of
the arethusa guards that saw him
initially tailing after the in groomers
and it wasn't a Birmingham it was a
merging gulen male and they are quite
big so that's what was happening here
and he's a little bit on the beaten up
side so he do need to also be careful
while we're walking
that wouldn't be a fun line to bump into
imagine an old male that so well had his
ego seriously bruised he could be
injured to the point where maybe he
can't hunt we don't really get any any
more information other than that so on a
bush walk probably application on a B so
you have to be have to be careful so we
don't want to be following his tracks at
all today now obviously with all the
lines as dynamics everything's changing
slightly whether your VOC is trying to
do come on in
um Beck's was at David or Daniel sorry
David there we go
and so David no I don't think that the
Birmingham boys would come in and
intervene in two different prides
fighting for the females
yes if there were other males that came
in most certainly that intervened they'd
wants to try and get rid of them and
take them out chase them away but not
for a dispute against two different
prize not at all they're just let things
be they might be curious by the sounds
but remember they know no different
the birmingham's will to see the
Torchwood prize they see the sticks
pride so for them it kind of means
absolutely nothing we still on the road
no we decided to move away from that
elephant and it just got too thick and I
don't know it well it's just we just had
a weird feelings we both decided that
we're gonna give him a skipping we're
gonna rather focus on finding a leopard
so it might be a little bit easier and
David yeah yes male and female lines do
get along and obviously the longer the
coalition of males is around and the
more frequently they visit the pride of
females they'll start forming a better
bond with one another but those males
not bound to one pride they can move
around and have more than one pride with
it so most of the time they get on if
it's a new coalition of males that's
taken over sometimes the females are
slightly hostile and they've got to earn
their place with the boys but normally
within a few months they sort of
one the girls over all-wise the girls
know and I want to make with the new
boys gonna find themselves well with a
few scratches possibly even dead so they
might only put up a fight for a little
bit well speaking of all these cats
I know Steve's trying to find lions but
brent has won the Safari because he's
found you elected to the sunset safari
there we go he's only about 50 meters
from where we left him in the morning
and it is ting Ghana still looking quite
hungry so he hasn't had any success
during the day there are some water back
not too far away but lots of open ground
between but it's a good spot to lie in
wait because you never know what might
wonder along the dam wall we often have
in parlour and all sorts coming through
yeah
hey as I said he was quite hungry this
morning so it might be worth playing the
patience game this afternoon with him
now it's amazing how much his territory
has shrunk in in just over a year say he
had massive amounts of territory I mean
let's get this get my bearings correct
yeah
well a very big welcome to Macy into a
brand-new viewer he is a boy he's a big
boy he's not in the best condition he's
quite an old boy as well and he used to
have a large territory but unfortunately
as he's got older younger males have
moved in and I sort of put a lot of
pressure on him so I know if we can
how's that work for you then said I can
okay so that little blue dot is where we
are now but certain ganas previous
territory basically used to encompass
like this his whole turkey further than
that his teacher used to encompass from
to do this it's think now from down here
where my finger is all the way around
like that up into that fence line across
to the north all the way down south here
all the way down to the kruger boundary
and then down and around again back now
his territory has shrunk from that
massive area to basically where we are
now and this sort of small square just
like that and he's got hooker Murray
pushing in from this side and he's got
quarantine pushing in from this side and
the side so he's lost the majority of
his territory in the last little while
and that he seems to have been surviving
on baby water backs around the chip to
Adam we've all been sort of joking it's
a it's a good retirement home for for
old lizards there's a constant supply of
decent food oh but he's a tired kitty
now so while he naps let's send you
across to Steve who you might have
caught up with the elephant tailor was
with yes I have we have got a beautiful
male elephant here
whoo it's just walking around us quite
cautiously he's not causing any trouble
or showing any sign of discomfort let me
try and just reposition so we can get a
better look at him as he comes down
towards the road
I heard reports of a breeding herd of
elephant and me headed in that direction
and we found a ball says marvelous is
the first elephant I've seen in some
weeks so actually I saw him this morning
when I was doing some tests with Juliet
but I think this is the same individual
the first elephants I'm showing you
lovely people in some time see if we can
just get in front of him the wind is
also playing a part a little bit of his
discomfort and he's on his own shame
poor guy the life of an elephant bull
lone they are
Jonathan Alicia and giraffe girl I'm
also very excited it's marvelous I
always loved seeing elephants and
because they always doing something you
know that was busy trying to just get a
little bit in front of him so we can see
what he's doing without causing him any
stress sorry Craig oh that's about as
good as we gonna get here see he's quite
relaxed the ours are soft hello my boy
believe that's a four and a half 5-ton
animal moving over there and hiding
behind the bush as well how easily he
hides moves up sorry Craig
what delicacy has he found now so
through observations I was talking last
night about looking at the fecal content
of animals dung to see what they're
feeding on connects you spend tommnow
and focus he's feeding on the wealth
area there the snake bat bush so that we
know for a fact because we can see it
happening and then analysis under
microscope will also give you the facts
of what's being fed upon and a lot of
animals make their ego is enjoying the
snake but bush a lot of animals make use
of the wild flowers this time of year
lots of nitrogen in them lots of
nutrients they will fade away in that
the coming weeks so it's good to make to
get all that nutrients in while you can
very selectively doing so with that big
trick and if you don't know what snake
Suwannee feather this is a hundred
percent live a hundred percent live with
a live African elephant who is showing
us his bottom right now let's move
around see if we can get on the other
side now he's feeding on some lovely
grasses underneath the tree and a little
three okay that's so much tannin in
magic worry wonder if he's actually
going to eat that branch or if he's
looking for the seed pods the little
berries Craig actually grabbed a handful
of berries just now and we drove past so
only feathered this is a lot big African
elephant walking pretty much straight
towards us and then he turned yeah we're
not causing him any harm
and to just move away and as comfortable
as they feel the need to be as close as
that feel the need to be okay well we're
gonna follow this bull for a bit longer
let's go back over to Taylor and see
what she's up to well look at what we've
got it looks like a bit of a crime scene
eh but I promise you it's not I think
this is one of the darkling beetles that
we're looking at it's very pretty
are you typically aren't quite round
having a sort of carapace like that with
little and what would you call that I
don't even know what words I'm trying to
find today but it's got sort of a very
bumpy back and it's got a long proboscis
as well but it's pretending to be dead I
promise you it's not dead is this is
this is actual thanatos asst and I think
when we found that maybe a hornbill or
something must have frightened it and
now it's pertaining to date and I'm
hoping he's simply that's long enough
yeah actually see it wake up now with
thinner choices it depends on the
species as to how long it will actually
last I'd from what I saw it because it's
just come alive again twice and then
gone back to sleep it takes of Arts I
don't know 30 seconds or so to a minute
I suppose it also depends on how long
the street is around remember animals
only perform Thanatos Azur typically if
they feel like there are under threat in
in some way they better move quickly
because there's an ant coming it might
tell us friends that you are dead when
you're not and the idea behind it is
that things that catch other animals
like well it's wriggling around I
suppose it's about the thrill of having
something that's alive and then and then
being able to kill it so if you're not
moving around anymore it might be a bit
on the boring side and then they tend to
leave it alone
please wake up you woke up in my hand
once so really got out but it was quite
funny the way that it sort of just stood
upright sensor was amazed you've never
seen anything like it before have you
thought it was some kind of Voodoo
what's going on I'm not exactly sure how
they do it come on wake up mas eu quite
surprised at the fact that this Beatles
plane did well I'm not just because I
suppose I know that lots of different
beetle species as well the snakes and
some lizards and oh there's a mite
twelve Thank You Rebecca I can see the
my thumb is a little a little mite
that's running around probably living on
on this little beetle well just quite
cool and so yeah so so Marcy I'm not
surprised about this I was surprised
though when we watched a mongoose he was
almost like he was looking for attention
as a little pup was trying to death
feign in front of a yellow-billed humble
now yellow ball at home was never going
to eat among those well I shouldn't say
never but the chances are highly
unlikely they have a completely
different symbiosis where they actually
help one another so I can't imagine that
this thing would just turn all of a
sudden please make up I don't know do
you think it likes my hand do you think
maybe it's because my hand is warm
let's try I'll be very gentle
also I've been pressing my hand against
the sand as you can see ghost shooter
and no I don't think it will bite me
it's got a long proboscis I have been
actually bitten by an assassin bag which
also has a proboscis I suppose it could
bite although it was crawling around on
my hand and didn't seem to bother too
much I didn't feel it trying to bite me
was actually just walking around was
very relaxed it was actually more
relaxed on my hand than anything so I
wonder if it was a little bit more
active because I'm obviously giving off
heat and on cooler days insects well not
really moving around too much wake up I
really just wanted to get up it will be
so cool if it does huh okay well we'll
see if we can get it to wake up again
we'll hold onto it for a little bit
longer I'm going to send you to Steve
who has got an elephant disappearing
into the bushes Thank You Taylor
well this elephant bull is slowly
meandering away from the red I'm not
gonna go following him off there and
then we don't get to see to me elephants
the last couple weeks but the
marvelous that we've been able to see
this nice big bull I thought Herbie and
Taylor had seen a breeding herd of
elephants I was quite excited to go find
them but this is the actual animal that
they saw I think and no breeding herd to
speak off so we're going to leave him to
his feeding and his slow meanderings
Casa the tusks do appear to be quite
small tasks are a genetic they really
are genetics and some of the larger
bulls yes we'll have bigger tasks but
you do get younger bulls with bigger
tasks it's all genetics all the lineage
I'd say he's probably between 25 and 30
so he's still he's quite a big boy but
it's just a genetic size that's going on
there that's all I can suggest he
doesn't have the biggest genes when it
comes to tusks and a lot of that had to
do with them with poaching in ivory
trade many many years ago that larger
Bulls were actually targeted for their
tusks and it's for reasons like that's
why down in the a telephone a tional
Park in the Eastern Cape we for a long
time didn't have any tasks in the
generation or in the population because
there was an individual by the name of
Pretorius who was responsible for
eradicating a huge sorry Gregor a huge
number of elephants in that area and he
got paid in ivory so he got paid for the
ivory he brought back so he selectively
only hunted or killed elephants that had
ivory we're talking over 100 years ago
but the the genetic the loss of those
genetics was very profound until about
maybe 40 years ago they introduced
Kruger elephants into Edda and the tasks
are coming back again there are a lot of
elephants still there males and females
included they have no tusks at all and
that's just a disadvantage for them when
it comes to feeding because they can't
guard the bark and access the
nutrient-rich cambium which is very very
necessary in the dry season then as we
know as we talk a lot about plants you
get lots of medicinal value from the
bark
in implants itself and if you don't have
a task it's very difficult to do that so
what is natural that is natural that
obviously that bottle net selection that
that man did in there was a problem so
here we have got a lone male in parlor
he has chosen to be oh there's like
another one over there I just caught
myself at okay but there's two there's
two male impala and now by no means in a
secure sort of location it is still a
little bit windy and they need to be
able to look over their shoulder and
also build up condition so this is where
they're sort of that the race comes in
you know this is where the race comes in
do the mail and parlour start defending
territories early or late and who's
going to be more successful sometimes
some of the guys start their sort of rut
or their territory demarcation maybe a
little bit too early and then by the
time the mating actually happens they
have lost all their condition and that's
all their condition then by that stage
they get eaten and die and then they
don't do any breeding search was wasted
but anyway that is the stories that are
going to continue on and on and on for
the next few weeks let's go to Taylor
who's beetle has woken up its woken up
look I told you it is not wait since are
you still shocked he's not died three
times for us and now he's awake in my
hand I don't know why he loves my hands
so much
he's needs to be very relaxed how cool
is that
now I will put him down we haven't gone
far from where we were and these are
incredible beetles they're from quite a
large family there's so many of them my
favorite is actually the racing striped
darkling beetle if you want to have
google it it's quite a funny thing to
look as of a very long legs I'm not I'm
not a kind of insane surgeon if this is
in fact darkling beetle just it really
looks like one what do you think it
could be a weevil a type of a weevil
maybe none of those patterns on the back
of very interesting either way I don't
know what it is it's one of the two may
be a weevil no I said thought darling be
initially see this is the hard part as
we start daunting itself and there are
so many beetles that look like one
another some mimic to look like certain
species so it can be a bit confusing
let's put him down since I'll release
him
bye-bye don't die now well pretend no
I'm not putting Union owes read ants
that will eat you anyways if it is a
darkling beetle they typically
scavengers off you go both know it is
down on the ground be safe
typically scavenging off carcasses or
even just watching vegetation and
they'll sort of go around and do that no
we stopped Jeremy I hope he was having a
look whose footprint is this was a
little Jenna track we'd like to have a
look-see
just over here in the mud well we're
actually looking for leopard tracks
that's what we ideally wanting to find
her little Janet was walking here
probably late last night oh my god I
can't see many more tracks but there was
definitely something going on here
there also here's a nice one since oh
yeah that's really cool you can quickly
have a look at this those actually said
to me that it was definitely from maybe
maybe earlier this morning because as it
walked see how it picked up some of that
mud maybe even had happened at some
point today cuz that looks almost
exactly the same anyways let's go to
brained now and I think he might also be
looking at paw prints well he's still in
the same spot
he's a little bit more alert than he was
when you last were with us which is
always a good sign as we know he is
quite hungry at the moment times have
been tough for the former dominant male
and to be interesting to see how long it
takes for quarantine and Coco Marie to
start pushing into this area as well I
think it's just a matter of time before
they do
as I said he is hungry Jilly but he can
still go a good couple of days maybe
even a week without a kill now often
when leopards are hungry like this they
will eat lots of little things that we
might not see like Terrapins and
squirrels and woof Mongoose and other
little snakes and what sort of titbits
to just just keep alive until they are
able to catch sort of something a bit
more substantial
and he's very flattered cat at the
moment so I heard he did come into
chitwa camp during the day actually had
a drink out of one of the the guest
rooms swimming pool so if he does have
any parasites maybe the chlorine will
sort him out as you can see he's found a
nice spot down behind the dam there's
quite a few little things around this
and water back this I mean parlor and
some Bush back I saw a little bit
earlier all very close to here so
there's lots of opportunities and
specifically if you just keep still here
you might get lucky enough that
something might just stumble onto him or
into him and that would make his life a
lot easier of course
and at the moment he's very tired kitty
there
now of course the main reason that a
leopard has spots or rosettes is for
camouflage at Katie's saying what's the
advantage of spots over stripes
that's an excellent question Katie well
leopards need to or they occur in such a
varied range of habitats that's what
that spots and rosettes are more sort of
useful it works in deserts it works and
forested works in Savannah where there
is tigers I suppose they do you have a
relatively varied varied habitats from
but mostly forested I suppose Savannah's
I'm not sure Katie I think they're both
work and leopards just seem to have
rosettes rather than spots I mean then
rather than stripes
we are next to that the dam yeah I say
and what he doesn't move well just might
have a look what's happening behind us
for a little while now of course the
nice thing about being around here is
that husana might make an appearance at
any any moment but it seems like steve's
i found a bird for draw a bird day it is
draw a bird a letter gentlemen please
take your screenshots immediately I have
no idea what bird this is absolutely no
idea I thought for a moment it was a
juvenile white crested helmets rack but
I don't know what it is it looks to me
to be a puppet of sorts but I don't know
please take your your screenshots and
then draw your bird if you want to we
are doing a um at the end of the show a
segment on all the bird pictures you
have drawn but who knows never stop
drawing Birds of fun we actually stopped
here there was a wonderful bird party
and there was an orange breasted Bush
racket I was trying very hard to get
crate to get it on camera but they are
impossible to get on camera and off goes
our little bit off it goes and with that
we are going to keep moving on oh he's
calling out his hunt top of the tree I
know what it is now listen to him later
gentlemen I can't believe I didn't
understand what he was
it is a rattling Cystic EULA but I think
it's a juvenile it's not making the full
call but anyway sorry about that let's
not take your screen shots it is one of
those funny little brown jobs that we
see it if you're not familiar with the
word little brown job LBJ's those little
funny ones that are very hard to
identify you need to take photos of them
to be able to get them and the rattling
circular is one of those until it calls
when it calls very very easy very very
easy okay so as we promised we're going
to move up towards people sort of damn
area to see if we can pick up on any
activity of the uncle homers and Lucy a
bird here that mimics like a Mockingbird
I don't really know anything about a
Mockingbird but we do get Birds yeah the
folks are jeonga is a very good Monica
so is the sobota lock as well as the
tropical booboo adds in or the southern
booboo adds in a whole lot of different
calls the whites Brad scrub Robin those
three birds that sell the most sort of
elaborate in their their mimicry and
yeah we do see we do see all of them
quite regularly and there are those
birds that can confuse you because they
make up all sorts of weird and wonderful
jumbles in there call the white Brad
scrub Robin will always do a three note
repeated so if you hear something you're
not sure and it kind of goes three times
and then it goes three times and and
then after about three minutes of
changes to another three notes repeated
when in doubt to white Brad scrub Robin
will so very hard to get them on camera
because as the name scrub
robin implies they like to hide in the
bushes
so I know when we started my segment
when I started with the first technical
glitches we were discussing heading up
towards before suck damp because the
Oklahoma pride was seen in the north
fighting with the Torchwood pride and
after a fight like that it's quite
common for cats to go and have something
to drink and to cool down somewhere so a
good bet would be to go and check the
dam and I'm feeling lucky
Craig you feeling lucky Craig's feeling
lucky what do you folks feel are we
feeling lucky today I think so Nick's at
Beck's is feeling lucky
the wind has calmed down a little bit
it's still windy but it was very
blustery before let's sail and see how
lucky she's feeling what's wrong with
everyone today we're feeling Toby how
lucky are we feeling how lucky are we
feeling we're not sure today with
deciding we've seen by the way we found
female labor tracks which is a good sign
so we're one step closer to where were
two from where we were but earlier but
nothing just yet we've seen sort of two
conflicting tracks we've seen sort of
some going towards like the elephant
carcass which is a bit south from here
and they made other tracks going north
along shoe-bomber we don't know what's
happening now it's been so windy so the
tracks that are in the sand looks super
disturbed but I know that that could
just be playing tricks on us so what we
thought we'd do is just come along here
to these little pans and see if
anybody's popped on down for a drink but
it doesn't look like it just yet so just
keep checking the agency see if there's
any spiders and things moving around and
the water's surface nothing just yet but
quiet everywhere
we aren't we as everything gone that's
how other days we'd come down here and
just be amazing filled with all sorts of
life not so much now okay
oh there's a spider's Hensel now have
one and you're also gonna hop over
you're gonna have to come to the side
just over there again is it
and there's a grasshopper can you see
the grasshopper moving in the water
sensor so you've got the spider here now
I wonder because that's a water spider I
wonder if it's going to go towards where
that grasshopper is it's desperately
flailing and trying to get out trying to
use that algae but is that going to lure
the spider in doesn't know that there's
potentially a meal for it a spider that
size I think would be able to do well
catch it but too late lucky draws
suppers made an escape and landed safely
on a piece of grass unfortunately for
the spider
it'll have to try and find something
else good luck off we go righty-tighty I
don't know I said rising tide you wanted
it here we go now
is he here somewhere just checking my
may have gone back onto the road again
this is a nice little jacuzzi hey that's
quite nice as a warthog that would be
fabulous but there's no warthogs and I'm
not getting in it and scenic we did lots
of different types of butterflies
unfortunately not many of them aren't at
the moment we're seeing a lot of African
monarchs see a lot of hair tails and a
kriyas lizard is a lizard
if you walk towards me I'm the
distraction you see where all those
sticks are come closer to me in there
there is a
don't know how to point it there's sort
of a stick that runs like this and then
you see when it touches some other
sticks just in they have you go up a
little bit I think I can you zoom out
for me I'm just having a look to try and
find it okay so let me try and put my
hand in it's kind of over there
somewhere I think even maybe a little
further DUP we're just trying to find it
it's in there oh you've got it you've
got it seems up yeah he's it's a little
head little sand felt blizzard of sorts
in his ear no nasals head look I'm just
going to descends on there we go so
there it is terrified as as the Giants
were walking through the grass and see
desperately trying to escape us but also
not be out in the open because we know
because we know that well there's lots
of warm rules around here and they would
love to eat a lizard like this many
different things there's a dozens would
like to eat something like this and
they've been a couple of them around so
it's going to stay hidden in that pile
of grass probably going towards the
water's edge which will be a great place
for it to go to because they seem to be
lots of insects we saw that grasshopper
that had landed in that lizard wouldn't
be afraid to run to the edge of the
water and grab something like that or
perhaps it's looking for some flies that
have sat down to race for the day that
would also be quite good right it seems
as though tengan is enjoying a Sunday
siesta when will you wake up I'm not
sure it's gone see if he's shown any
signs of waking up just yet
well I just got some good news that I've
passed on to Steve that there is a male
lion apparently visible from the
boundary dari Mane with Gauri mane so
that's good news so he's gonna go see if
I'm sure Steve we'll see if we can find
that male line
tango however has not moved a muscle so
let's maybe try move around get a
different view of him while he's still
snoozing down there now that we're the
only people here patience pays off when
it comes to big cat sightings
not the best view of him let me just try
I can get a little window for them to
see his see his face it's about as good
as it gets vamp it now child of the
universe is asking about females sexual
selection of males they don't really
have they're not too picky that will
mate with any male that is dominant and
in the area that surrounds their their
territory now they won't you mate with
young males that are not going to hang
around but they will mate with any
dominant adult male who holds territory
even that holds territory outside of
their natal home range and that's that
if the male happened to take over from
one of the other males the fact is that
this male might believe that the Cubs
are his so he's hungry there's lots of
food around and also of course staying
here is always good because hasanah
might make an appearance to come harass
cindyana as well
poor tired
okay well it sounds like a Steve is on
his way to look for some alliance so
let's go join them yes we are still
heading in the direction of where our
potentially think the Lions may be I
mean we're only about five minutes away
from before sook damn obviously we've
taken a bit of a detour we were almost
here earlier and they went back because
we had some technical issues of the
vehicle as I'd said so before
but it seems like signal is staying nice
and strong with us now and we'll be at
the dam in a few minutes and hopefully
we'll find ourselves some lions wouldn't
that be marvelous for the afternoon I
won't drink sorry Conrad Conrad's the
tick my very good friend in the in the
FC they used as all the technical stuff
and I'm sure by the end of the week he's
gonna fall his hair on his head he said
don't jinx it please sorry Conrad our
instincts it's everything seems to be
good at the moment what a marvelous
afternoon it's so nice having this
breeze it really cools things down
thanks the edge of things so to speak
and as I think Brent already said the
beautiful thing about wind is that you
often will find predators actually
moving because of their ability to to
stalk and hunt with a little bit less
stealth and also the wind picks up the
smell of the animals and brings it
towards them and it's like chocolate
cake to those who enjoy chocolate it's
an irresistible so to speak
but I don't know if you folks on the
camera can you viewers at home can
notice how green everything is from that
rain we had two days ago two or three
days ago I can't remember but there's
such a green tinge to everything all the
grasses are are sort of flashing again
and it's very very cool to see every
single little mud wallow pan I've gone
past is full the any concern is we are
tailored or jus bottom is looking very
very low in water Oh something in the
eye I don't know why it is so low it
must have a really bad catchment because
the rain we had the other night there
come the gremlins let's go over to that
flat captain Donna he is truly still a
very flat cat so we are hoping he's
gonna get moving at some point today but
it is still quite warm as I said he was
quite active today he went into two to a
larger home he had a drink in the pool
he tried to look for some bush back in
camp and went to visit the staff village
I say you did have a bit of a busy day
after after we left him this morning but
he hasn't moved very far in total
oh yeah
sorry just the radio is going at the
moment so as you can see is still
sleeping
okay well he continues to nap let's send
you back to Taylor hopefully you'll be
up on the move shortly look at this it
is the biggest crab spider I think I've
ever seen in my entire life is so fat so
so so that I'm actually I'm just turning
it to have a look myself and sitting on
a well theoria plant hoping that some
bees maybe there be flower perhaps some
ants or maybe even little beetles of
sorts and bugs or come and feast off of
the flowers off of the nectar the pollen
and that the wealth area flowers will
have seen the done Rico web they need to
hunt actively normally they're well
camouflaged and well in this case you
can see it's not particularly well
camouflaged but if it just sits very
still
it might get lucky and something won't
spot it only something else but that's
quite cool it's quite big I'm going to
show you another thing since all this
looks like a little wee you know it's
quick no one show yourself to us on here
we go
is that behaving well since all that for
you I'm just encourage it to go that way
so a little weevil by the looks of it
Ulster Ulster
I'm sorry feasting on the flowers and
then there's even a little ant in it you
might have to turn around just slightly
just up on top yeah it's lots of these
the weevils actually and so going back
to the spine and joy I can't see if it's
upside down then we find it for you okay
so if you look at it this way I'm gonna
try and hold the well serious stems
quite steady as its heat is up yet so
its heat is at the top and the rest of
it is it's a fuller thorax there's no
just there difference between em but
abdomen and the thorax it's sort of just
one with a spider and what is it what is
sitting on my arm
no it's gone little bunny flies I think
trying to get all the sweat and all
sorts of other things but quite cool
very pretty it's a
any fat one there one if it's a female I
mean my hand
obviously Dwarfs a spider but in
comparison to the other crab spiders we
have seen it's probably about four or
five times that size so it just goes to
show there's lots and lots of lots of
different things all yours mating
beetles mating little weevil sorry can
you see them keep it nice and still they
don't seem to be too bothered by me
doing what they've got to do let's make
little baby weevils very cool there we
go bases you say Beth or bin sorry each
time it's broken up I think you've said
Beth who I'm going to be answering nah
there we go
wonderful no that's perfect I've got it
enough so hello young Taylor who's only
ten years old mini-me you've got blonde
hair maybe you do have blond hair
perhaps your mum can send a photo for
you I believe your mom has just told us
that you're quite scared of insects and
geckos and lizards I promise you there's
nothing that you need to be worried
about obviously you don't want to touch
any insects that you don't know so and
if you know what it is rather not
handled and it's actually just best to
leave them on their plants they'll be
quite happy like I wouldn't pick that
spider just because I know I'm gonna
upset it the only spiders that I will
touch and I'm also don't like spiders
very much not on me I like to look at
them as a jumping spider because it's
really cool we can make them jump from
one hand to another maybe you should do
that maybe you should you can ask your
mom's trying to help you find and
identify a jumping spider because
they're quite easy to sort of find
they're very hairy and that's how I got
over my sort of fear of spiders is that
I put one on my hand and then I realized
that they would jump from surface to
surface and when you look at them up
close they've got so many eyes and big
big buggy eyes and they're really hairy
in there quite pretty and you think to
yourself how is that a scary little
thing so you don't worry about it too
much but some I wouldn't probably
wouldn't pick up a cockroach oh you
don't have to touch all insects you
don't have to give them big cuddles
sometimes
should just watch him from a distance
but I promise you you don't need a
screen you don't need to do any of those
things because they are more terrified
of you than you are of them so I'd like
to see a picture tailor of you and the
bug and see if we can get over your fear
together anyways Steve however is not
looking at creepy and crawly sees at
levels of dam and he's got some rather
large mammals in the water yes we do
Thank You Taylor
and there is the male hippo and he is
joined by two females who just went
underwater before you came to us and
it's quite nice to see a resident hippo
here now with with a lady or to his
little pod the swimming specialists of
the African wilderness here we go doing
a little bit of diving for themselves
they don't have any of the the technical
equipment that we need for diving and on
that note we are going to be well wild
Earth is starting a new project called
dive live which we are very excited
about and the support is coming through
we appreciate all the feedback and we've
put together a little something from
hippos diving in the African savanna to
humans diving in the ocean I started my
career as a scuba diving instructor and
I was lucky enough to travel all around
the world diving in the most spectacular
locations and now we're getting back to
my roots our new mission is to take you
live underwater
what we're gonna do is we're gonna have
a marine biologist underwater with a
full face mask so they can answer your
questions and talk to you in real time
you will be able to sit in your living
room at home and ask a question about
the underwater world to somebody who's
under the ocean on the other side of the
planet we are developing a system that
will allow us to talk underwater you to
be able to hear us and clearly it's a
real challenge it's never been done
before
properly we're coming along really well
leopard moray eel look at that the next
thing to do is to get a team answer to
get a boat to set up camp and just start
getting it up and running the incredible
diversity efficient
[Music]
dive live is the way we're gonna get
everybody in the world the opportunity
to connect with nature this is our
mission
as a quote from jane goodall and that is
only if we understand what we care only
if we care will we help and only if we
help will all be saved we are a
community from all over the world
that get together a couple of times a
day to share our passion and love of
nature we broadcast fre live in two
schools around the world which enables
the Future custodians of our planet the
students to fall in love with nature if
you pledge to this dive Life Project and
come on this mission with us you'll be
able to be there for the first month
which will be a private access
experience when you can help us develop
dive life into being what we believe it
can be but then also you've got to join
us virtually on our premiere party after
our first public broadcast
so join us in testing the technology
finding the experts and setting up camp
this is such a great opportunity for us
to make a difference we can get people
all around the world to fall in love
with our oceans and that's such an
important thing to do come along with us
it's our mission make it yours
we can make a real difference
[Music]
there is hello everybody I hope you
enjoyed that little segment we are still
without hippos hello
it just popped his head down it is a
little cold with the wind the wind has
picked up quite dramatically since we've
been sitting here at the dam and look
what we spotted with our eagle eyes what
is that what could that be
looks like a puddle of lions ladies and
gentlemen the Oklahoma prize yeah they
are lying up just on the other side of
the dam from where we are
I've had them there before a couple
times and they look like they are very
very relaxed I can't see how many
animals are there there's a few of them
lying flat in the grass sir are we gonna
go around to the other side there and
see if we can get a bit of visual I
think it's the uncle rumors I'm only
guessing that I know the Torchwood's who
has seen interacting with the uncle
homes this morning and I've never seen
the tortured prior to come into Juma so
I'm assuming that it must be lions that
we know quite well but very hard to see
you can't see any recognition of them
because they are flat and far away so I
hippos are submerged again we're going
to start up and go around onto the other
side and get a nice close to looking at
these cats
everyone's keen I'm sure Linden's are
off girl thank you very much you know
there is luck in the air and it's what
you've noticed those of you who watch
the show is that these animals they
follow water you know they need to drink
and when it gets hot just go have a look
around the shady spots I mean you can
obviously hear often how whenever we go
on Drive we always go and check the
water points it's always a good sort of
starting point just these animals will
be and yeah so there we are marvelous
marvelous stuff
and they were almost visible until the
one raised his head so Alisha a human
would most certainly get sick if they're
drank that water just like that but
there are ways of filtering it you know
when you do wilderness safaris you're
quite often take either iodine tablets
or fluoride tablets should I say and you
put next to a water saw oh yeah seems
like Steve's fighting off some gremlins
hopefully he'll be back with the
incredible in calm as soon as you can
see mr. t is still an absolute flat cat
almost looks like he's really really
enjoying his late afternoon snooze
that's a strange noise I've been hearing
I'm trying to figure out what it was but
I actually think it's wind going through
the tower dad Finn walk walk Internet
looks like we'll be okay though
it's very very peaceful here at the dam
at the moment a very very peaceful big
cat he gets moving shortly
now it's quite an old leopard our mr. t
and so far it is yeah is mostly you know
it's probably could have been from a few
scratches from a fight with another
leopard but most of the the damages to
his ear are made by a very small species
of fly called a stable fly and those
bites on his on his ears actually cause
the older leopards that have had the
bites for many many many moons to
actually become quite affected by it as
you can see if you have if we could have
a look at the back of it and you can you
would be able to see quite clearly the
damage that those flies have inflicted
on the Leopards ears
he's very very relaxed kitty at the
moment
it's always nice to spend quality time
with the cats even when there are
snoozing rather than being active and
you've got to spend the long hours with
them to get that incredible activity
from time to time as otherwise if you
rush off too soon you're not going to
see that incredible behavior
I hold Stan garden out of 12 he's around
12 Amsterdam life expectedly expectancy
of a leopard a wild leopard can vary
quite heavily we had a male called him
voula I think he managed to survive to
about 14 as he sort of evaded the other
big males including this one but
generally between 12 and 14 is the life
expectancy of a male leopard in the wild
and then life expectancy of a female is
generally a little bit longer maybe
after 1516 and he's he's been pushed
into a very small area now by two other
males say he's sort of it the retirement
village here next to the dam there's
lots of food around and there's lots of
water he doesn't have to move too far to
get everything he needs
I can we're gonna watch a little bit
longer to see what and see what happens
and let's go see Steve he's got the
smallest member of the order carnivora
did you see him please gentlemen it's
busy shouting at us so little dwarf
Mongoose between would have their head
wobble but from the smallest carnival we
have to the uncle rumor puddle or as
Chris it was Beck said in my ear at
Christmas bed and for those of you out
there who have never heard of a
Christmas bed it's when you have
families around and all the kids and you
throw all the mattresses together in the
lounge with all sorts of blankets and
pillows and put on a DVD or two and then
all the kids sort of slumber together in
one big Christmas bed it's something we
refer to in South Africa whenever a
whole lot of you jump together on one
bed yeah I still do it as well Beck's
pig says she still does it I still do it
it's quite fun and then then we need
popcorn and chocolate not sure if
they're going to stay just here
how cute are they so at least three of
them a moment ago another adventurous
one to the left having a little bit of a
groom beautiful little place for them to
hide last time actually with Craig he
was at with me where we'll just maybe a
hundred and fifty meters or so just but
further east from where we are right now
and we had the Oklahoma's lying up on a
termite mound and then right at the end
of show just as we ended family of dwarf
mongooses erupted out of the termite
mound and the Lions including the adult
lionesses ran and jumped and that was
the funniest thing I think I've ever
seen and then there
and land on the whole the Mongoose
disappeared and then tentatively lift up
their port to the kind of needed to see
what exactly they might've caught but
they didn't catch anything and just way
too fast
back to the puddle what is he doing
there is he busy eating she is he eating
a stick keeping the teeth clean they do
look rather hungry a bellies are or
rather empty you see this this one on
the far right Krieger the far right they
can just see on a bum a little bit of a
wound there that looks like it's new
under fix if see every seen this wind
yet it's not that injured Linus hmm I
mean they interacted with the
Torchwood's this morning apparently
there was quite a bit of hustle and
bustle between them Tristan was actually
showing me a little video Nikki Nikki
knows the lines very well by their faces
but not by their bottoms hmm what was
that but you can see lions every single
day and something can happen in the
night and you'll see them the next day
and there can be all sorts of weird and
wonderful things but there definitely
had an interaction and I would be
surprised if there no fresh scars or
injuries on any of these animals because
a territorial dispute between lionesses
can be very very very aggressive they
are fighting for everything they hold
dear to themselves but then Brent did
tell me that they actually are related
to their torch with pride and the uncle
homers
so I didn't know that but very
interesting so maybe that's why in the
video that we saw it wasn't such an
aggressive sort of attack it was more
posturing and growling and a lot of
chasing and a few individuals got a bit
of a hiding but it was nothing like what
you see when when the going is very
tough you can see lions they will
actually really they'll kill each other
if they can what have you spotted their
youngster Koren I am trying to do a
headcount I'll reposition shortly and
see if we can get the rest of them but
I've I've counted I think 10 I believe
Brent said this morning that they're
only sought 10 I didn't see 11 but we'll
do a count shortly and we'll make sure
that they're all here but our first
counter that only saw 6 and then slowly
more and more okay so ladies gentlemen
were just going to hold off speaking for
them but while we do a broadcast
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
welcome to Juma in the sabi sands South
Africa we are sitting with the pride of
lions called the Inca Huma pride which
numbers up to 11 individuals we're up in
the northwestern sorry northeastern
section of Jummah itself and my name is
Steve Falconbridge good afternoon
welcome and I'm joined by Craig on
camera and we are in the heart of South
Africa and the heart of the wilderness
and this is a tourism destination of
note the Oklahoma pride which we see
lying very very flat at the moment had
an interaction with another pride just
to the north of us this morning and one
of the landowners to the north actually
took a video to show the interaction as
it took place and as we know lion prides
and lions that we find all over the
African continent and here are very well
documented in the sabi sands South
Africa and that is because we do get to
spend a lot of time with them Reese I
haven't seen a male with this pride for
some time there's reports on the radio
that there's a male lion down right down
in the far southwest to the complete
opposite corner of Jummah itself and he
or the Birmingham boys as they are
called are the dominant pride males they
will look over most of the prides in the
area and they don't take part in any of
these pride disputes the pride disputes
are tackled between the lionesses what
we're looking at here is the family unit
the the lionesses who dominates and lead
the pride wherever it goes and that's
made up of the offspring and in this
pride is only one juvenile male of about
16 17 months old so the Cubs are still
quite young there is one of the Cubs
they're about the same sort of age it's
trying to get nice and close and
personal with its mother but a grooming
hazel they are such beautiful creatures
and we are so blessed to be able to
spent
with them and in places like the sabi
sands if you do ever decide to come and
visit you can get up close and personal
with these cats you can get some amazing
photography and it is also a world-class
destination for Leopard don't let me
don't think because we can get close in
person that these animals are tame by no
means tame the bitumen process that's
gone on for many many years with regards
to game viewers is exactly what enables
us to view them from such a close
distance so the temperatures are quite
warm in the daytime but we're gonna go
to my friend Brent who's sitting with
another very special cat yes in South
Africa is an absolutely amazing place to
see the big cats of Africa and we are
still sitting with this male leopard his
name is Tinga Anna and he wants huge
amounts of pressure from hawk amore and
quarantine so he is shrunk and his
territory shrunk enormously the moment
he's looking a little bit hungry he's
looking a little bit worse for wear he's
had a tough couple of months and he's
lost probably three-quarters of his
territory in the last year two other
male leopards moving in but he is still
one of the most beautiful cats I've had
the privilege of spending many many
hours with hi Steph Steph we are
currently in the sabi sands Game Reserve
which is about 60,000 hectares
about 150,000 acres we are sitting on an
exquisite property called cheat - a
cheat - a private game reserve and there
are different sizes but chip has
probably got traverse of around 10,000
hectares or so so you're able to
traverse and in a day very easily see
all of Africa's big five
isn't that beautiful as wasa animals in
the Kruger are not tame at all they are
wild but they are habituated to the use
of vehicles so if you need to get out of
the car he would probably run away and
all behave aggressively so they are used
to the vehicles however there are still
a hundred percent wild the greatest
greater Kruger ecosystem is 2.7 million
hectares over five million acres of
unfenced wilderness
okay now isn't this incredible we were
able to explore Africa on foot as well
so let's go across to my friend Taylor
it is pretty amazing to be walking
around in an area infested with leopards
and lions will confess that sounds like
a bad word doesn't it but it isn't my
name is Taylor mccurdy
and on camera with me today is Senzo and
we are walking around our chair in the
sabi sand volton in the great Kruger
National Park now we are being very
careful as we walk I'm gonna go this way
around and I'll meet you on the other
side we are not necessarily looking for
the bigger animals today we've been
focusing on a lot of small things you've
been seeing really cool spiders really
cool beef flies and velvet and scent
grasshoppers and all sorts of amazing
things our chair which is really really
cool in this that's just one of the
greatest activities better so it's
almost got caught on a tree and one of
the activities you can do while you're
out here on safari one thing that seems
has got to do though with all his camera
equipment is be very very careful they
doesn't trip over anything now we did
have an elephant bull not to far away
from here he was moving in this
direction going towards some pants so
we're really hoping we might be able to
bump into him it has also been
exceptionally windy today
which is not the greatest thing when
you're out on a bush walk because well
inhibits you being able to hear very
well and we rely on our senses
exceptionally well archer when you're on
foot Cindy you've said it's only 20
hours to New Yorker from New York to
Johannesburg what are you waiting for
jump on a plane come and join us perhaps
I could take you out on a bush walking
experience and so that's the plan is
we're actually aiming for these little
mud wallows that are not too far away
because it's been really hot the wind is
now dying down so it's turning out to be
a most perfect afternoon for a bush walk
and perhaps we're going to get the
largest land mammal having a mud bath
but in just a few meters away so we'll
keep our eyes up and hopefully find some
really cool things I'm gonna see send
you over to Stevie's not too far away
from me probably just a few kilometers
away way he's got some hippo
yes and you're back with us and we are
still at the dam bill the sukkah Dam and
we don't just have lions and leopards
here we've also got very large
hippopotamus living in the dams as well
and they are so important for the
diversity of these rivers and dams
because of the organic material that
they deliver in the river in the form of
their dung which feed a numerous amounts
of vegetation eating or vegetation
eating a fish and there's plenty of
birds that feed on them so with the
hippos we have now got a couple of the
Lions store with us here with their
heads up isn't that a gorgeous young
animal youngster about 14 15 months of
age doing very very well in this pride
Mohamed from the DRC welcome I'm so
happy to have you on the show
marvelous I'm suppose is quite nice for
you at the time the DRC is probably
quite similar ah look at those teeth
quite similar with regards to the time I
know a lot of our are the viewers are
either watching very early or very late
in the evening isn't that beautiful
you see the pink on the nose is often
something to look at for aged giraffe
girl you need to come it is on your
bucket list it is a wonderful place to
come look at those teeth so often Lions
when they start licking themselves will
then or start yawning they'll start
licking and then up they'll get and
start doing some movement you might
first see an ablution stop so they start
with some grooming start with some
licking they might have a toilet stop
Koki the the African lion is Panthera
leo and I think the the lions did you
might find else I'm trying to think
where else you fight lions in the world
I am I've hit an absolute blank right
now I know that they are unique this
species is unique to Africa that might
move through in
is sort of the the Easter Middle East
area but I honestly do not have an
answer for you right there
terribly sorry and here one of the
lapwings in the background
fantastic giraffe girl with your safari
savings keep up the good work we look
forward to seeing you on the African
continent in Juma sabi sands South
Africa near future and on that note
ladies and gentlemen thank you for
joining us on this very short broadcast
I hope you have a marvelous evening
further if you'd like to watch more
please Google Safari live and continue
the show have a good evening
look at her bum oh that looks so sore
doesn't it that looks like it's been
opened it was looking a lot better the
other day and it's possible that she got
into the altercation again Oh shame
what a pity but they're starting to get
up the wind is up much cooler than it
was half an hour ago time for a bit of
play she is the oldest lioness in the
pride and is she still doing rather well
she's potentially the mother to most of
them well granny anyway
meena think they do develop arthritis I
can't tell you for sure but one thing
that you do see in in Lyons in sort of
the Kruger Park area is they do develop
TB and they start losing condition at an
older age and the T B's there are from
the buffalo and you'll often see them
suddenly losing very very a lot of
condition getting very skinny and the
bones to guard and they seem to get
swellings on the elbows almost like a
gout but it is in fact actually TB that
they've contracted and whether that's
got anything to do with your question
about arthritis I'm not sure but it
seems like they do get a bit old and
stiff but where there's actually a
diagnosed disease or a fiction I'm not a
hundred percent sure but look at that
Craig oh we have got some enormous
clouds building up on here ours and
ladies gentlemen and have a look at that
that is a huge development coming in
from the West we're going to watch it
very carefully because that could get
everybody very wet but it could be the
rains that we are looking for the rains
that will fill this dam up to the brim
hopefully the viewer Taylor dam as well
or I could just tease us and just swoop
straight past in the opposite direction
we're not sure oh there's some lovely
grooming going on there Oh mom this is
just such a nice life so I'm trying to
see that youngster one of the youngsters
had a very bad eye last time I saw them
but I haven't quite seen it yet they
haven't all risen or lifted their heads
up it this youngster is looking in fine
condition very loved well actually
there's two of them getting licked at
the same time they're how marvelous is
that that's how you do it mom when you
got more than one cub just lick across
it's a little bit of jealousy going on
there my turn my turn
nope she's going
to lick yourself hopefully they'll get
up and get quite playful with us again
as we've seen them before
think I was with Dave that one afternoon
and the more whitey where the Cubs all
started jumping up and playing and there
seems to be some movement here some
youngsters there we go up they climb
increasing the size of the puddle there
we go I'll just lie right on your face
that's a Christmas bed indeed ok so
that's another youngster and its eyes
looking fine that's three youngsters
there that's eyes are looking fine to me
so I'm thinking the one that we used to
see is a little bit more on the left
maybe it will show itself soon as one of
the adults not heard turn for some love
reciprocating that's marvelous that were
able to spend time necklace with
Wildcats Calum
how many Lions to take down a hippo so
that is an enormous number i watched
video years ago friends of mine were
doing work for National Geographic and
they formed 20 lines on the back of a
hippo and the hippo still won that
battle so a hippo is not to be messed
with there really are an enormous animal
with a really low sense of gravity so
you first need to be able to pull it
down and then you need to be able to
suffocate it and it's very hard to do I
don't think you need to be a really big
pride alliance with a few males I'd say
more than 20 with some males in there it
could probably do it but the risks
involved are enormous bless you
there's the cat stretch the yoga lovers
out there that was a beautiful cat
stretch
Peggy this is the time of day lions
start getting up and getting mobile and
they will hunt now if something presents
itself or they'll start moving in that
direction to hunt but if anything does
happen you know if something happened to
come across them while they were lying
here they would definitely try and pull
it down most definitely yes I mean you
look at the youngster there okay well
our lions are started to move brent has
moved off because his teen Ghana is nice
and flat and let's see what he's up to
well he was so flat and there were so
many cars trying to get in there and
seems like he's the only leopard that's
been found so there's a lot of cars
there so lots of traffic so we're gonna
move off I'm gonna go see which male
lion that one is on our boundary so
we're gonna have a quick look there and
maybe should you lose got up and about
and you never know in this area
Hazama could pop out at any moment
very strange weather this afternoon I
don't think we're gonna get any rain out
of it too windy generally if you get
rain you don't get a lot of wind
beforehand
it's on their own yeah he likes the
sports quite often on the little pad a
pet
it's gonna be on the game Drive radio
quickly to find out how many people are
at the lion how many stations with
Maryland at Triple M diamond
complex please no tapes number one okay
so we are faced standby so we'll just
slow me enjoy we're in that direction
now someone else who seems to be moving
quite slowly this afternoon is Taylor
mccurdy so let's see where she's off to
next
Oh live live was that thunder
I think I did just here but a thunder in
the distance I think there's gonna be a
big storm coming over actually come to
care look at this coming in he says it's
wind I didn't know when did it color
though
he's got nah it looks like all the dust
has been stirred he's on another but you
can just sort of see coming from the far
east and Brent was saying that they
seemed like there was a storm off the
coast of Mozambique which most certainly
would get us we're only about 150
kilometers as a crow flies from
Mozambique can you believe that
obviously would go along the roads it's
probably about I don't know two hundred
and seventeen kilometers away something
like that maybe a bit more maybe close
to 300 KS but we're not going to be
going to the beach today unfortunately I
would love to go there oh it would be
quite nice work on my socket and get rid
of that and no we're just finally making
our way out towards quarantine because I
have a sneaky suspicion with all this
cloud cover coming in not a sneaky
suspicion is obvious that the clouds are
going to cover the Sun it's going to get
a lot darker
I love cricket and earlier than it
normally would we want to be prepared we
want to make sure we aren't too far away
from home so we'll go bumble about on
quarantine I had no luck on that leopard
though the ground was just so badly
disturbed it was almost impossible for
us to actually see what was going on the
tracks that we were looking at I mean
they look like they're about six days
old but they weren't because you could
see they were over the top of the
vehicle tracks from this morning Safari
it was just very difficult and she
bomber was not the greatest road to
track on there aren't big sections worth
sort of hard graveled areas so he
decided to sort of just move out
especially with a fading light and we've
been looking for insects I've once seen
a ladybug down here maybe we will see
another ladybug
I don't know oxpeckers don't think I'm
able to see them they're flying over the
head of us now going to look for a spot
to roost I'm sure we can just hear that
as they fly we go it's checked there's
some more grassy sections coming out
maybe we'll find some more oh very nice
well something since on I should
probably do is hydrate but then Gorman
lionesses are on it yes rehydration is
good just like these lines now are
rehydrating so line is right here next
to our car we'll look at in a moment
once we finish watching this Lions drink
who's got a damaged eye I have not been
able to find the youngster with an
injured eye which is marvelous to see
says if it just healed in the space of
rough for days when asked that I seen it
I was last week
so there are you living living lions
here they are looking in a really good
condition a few cuts and scratches as I
said will show you this one line here
soon she's got a bit of an injured I
mean oh male lions were generally fight
against each other but if a male line is
threatening a pride he's threatened in
the Cubs it is not uncommon for females
to gang up into to repel a male lion it
does often happen and but see there
she's got she's the blind one actually
he's pretty she used to be called pretty
but there's another one on the right of
me here that's gonna walk past us soon
that's got something really weird in its
eye first is going to go find out what
that little ones playing with it's found
a little what are you doing found a
little
of Plec plastic piping apologize for
that folks and you see there's something
wrong with her eye there if we can get
in on that are what are you doing
wend if that's her youngster well we are
surrounded by lions at the moment folks
see look at that so weird lad vessel
type of thing very hard to explain but
the I have on a little bit of a sty or
something
hi everyone and welcome back
seems like Steve's having some problems
and we are making our way towards a male
line now and then hopefully she Dooley
will be around as well and this is where
she crossed in earlier today and had a
drink so she could have laying up in the
thicket somewhere now for sensitive
viewers I'm gonna warn you about this
this male lion before we get there he's
not in good shape he is a Magellan male
lion and he is right at the end of his
life apparently years very emancipated
so he's not well and he was trying to
follow the in comas this morning to try
see if he could get an easy meal
so I don't know if it's a line we've
ever seen before the mijung Gallants not
in my time vim beings never seen him a
jingle inhaler but apparently he is he
is very very ill I'm not Tristan or no
better than me the Magellan's arrived
after I left the sabi sands but I think
he must be 1314
so that's old for a male lion now
remember this is the African wild the
stuff happens every day we can't only
show you the popcorn all sort of that
the popcorn and ice cream everything's
pretty everything's nice so this is
still a very interesting scenario and a
lot of people ask what happens to a male
lion when he gets old so this is a very
good opportunity for us to show you what
what happens to a male line now
he could he might even apparently he's
so bad that you might even be killed by
the females if they decided to turn on
him the in corners mighty he's not a
Birmingham they still have sub-adults
the birmingham's found him they would
definitely kill him so the same goes for
the Volkers take that opportunity to
remove an adult male lion out of out of
the system
so just so everyone is warned if you are
sensitive and you might not want to see
this line
so it should be around here somewhere
we're getting close
ah well I head towards the sad lion
sighting let's go to taro who's gonna
cheer you up with some pictures from
draw a bird dead the sad lion sighting
that sounds terrible anyway so cuz we've
got for you something that you're not
allowed to see a rhinoceros that is in
the form of my cell phone cover I
suppose I need this now don't I as most
of you know it is willed draw a bird day
and I hope that you put your pins to the
paper and had a bit of fun I know I did
and mine was absolutely horrific so I
have two of my favorite bird pictures
and this one is called the purple bird
and it was drawn by our very own Tula
Ann and Tucker well done that's very
very good
I absolutely love it and then there's
one more no that's a plant which way is
fine going to make a turn technology
really doesn't like me it doesn't want
to stay we might have to everybody
doesn't want to stay ok
sans oh I think we may have one there we
go we won I figured it out
look at me good thanks so
technologically advanced Sam you thank
you so much for drawing this I'm trying
to guess what it is is it a green
African green pigeon or is it a parakeet
I'm not actually sure you're going to
have to tell me which one it is but well
then I couldn't decide who was the
winner between the two of you because
you both did such an outlaw the three of
you because you both all three of you
did an outstanding job that's what I'm
trying to say so well then very nice I
might have to try and have them print it
out and put in my room so we're still
making our way up towards there the big
wide open plains of quarantine and hope
to see our friend the wildebeest one
last time before the Sun sets behind the
horizon but we've still got a little a
way to go and now what we're also going
to do is Herbie at some point is gonna
draw a bird I think what we might do cuz
he's up there I saw him practicing in
the sand as we might try and catch up to
him sit him down on log and get him to
draw us a bird right off you go to Steve
who's still with the hippos
yes we are we are with the lines and
these hippo came really quite close to
the bank and we're displaying at the
waiting lines showing them their teeth
that they're much bigger than the lion's
teeth and the Lions are very interested
and we've given him a proper little
stare down we've got four of the adult
lioness and a youngster lying right next
to our car
I dare even start the engine they are so
close you can see a bit of the door in
the bottom right hand frame of the
picture there they are yawning soon I'm
sure after their drink they will be
getting ready to move in a certain
direction and check which direction the
wind is coming from mmm wind is coming
kind of from the West which is to go
directly south or north from here so
let's hope they choose to go south they
go south we'll be able to well attempts
to follow them if they go north well we
will lose them in about a hundred meters
as they cross into buffa souk here we go
here comes that one lioness is now
moving there is the cat stretch oh and
the yarn and its hope they go in that
direction because that is where we would
like them to go she might have a little
drink now such beautiful animals
okay always happens after a bit of
movement and have a toilet stop Jane
male lion stock remains from about seven
months eight months very very small
though - about a year they start and
then they fully developed in the bath
between three and a half and four try
and find the young male here and where
he is the one up on top of the rock yeah
he's the one on top there
that's him you can see he's just a
little bit of fur around the neck it's
not very very prominent there's a little
bit more on the back of his head so
between about a year and maybe 12 months
12 months to 14 months they'll start
developing that sort of fur we'll see
there's a bit of genetics involved I'm
just gonna keep quiet for a moment
they're making little contact call
noises
they have still got a piece of plastic
part uncle homers are very naughty when
it comes to playing with things but
obviously we shouldn't have plastic part
lying around
so obviously evidence of old sort of
plumbing or pumps to to access the water
in and around here
seems to me like the Lions were really
enjoying the sunset Kaelin the Lions Inn
in South Africa most them don't swim
very very well or when joy swimming
Kreger do you never look at the hippo
yeas behaving in a very strange manner
and go as the defecation all the Lions
are transfixed on these big big juicy
looking mammals and lions do stay away
from water here doesn't mean that corn
to swim that's they don't choose to swim
let's see what reaction happens here I
don't know what's going on he's moving
very quickly towards the bank
the lions are very interested they just
can't help but react to something that
moves
so Tigers yes are very very common in
water and but up in the Okavango Delta
there's lions that spend a lot of time
very submerged there because the habitat
they've grown up in is very swampy and
they're chased animals through the flats
through the the mud flats and the water
so those lions do very very well in
water but I've watched Lions many times
hiss leopards lions hiss at a puddle of
water or a stream that's crossing the
road they don't like it very much what a
marvelous shot Kruger purfles hook
provides again yet again provides us
with some magic
well it looks like Herbie has finished
doing his drawing let's go over to her
being Taylor and have a look I'm just
pretending I'm joking there's no
freeze-frame I just wanted to scare
everybody and then if see anyways
so since also jumped in on the
competition oh my pages right this over
here is her B's beautiful drawing it is
a hammock up fishing and then this good
over yeah is actually the nest and
there's a little chicken side waiting
for mom or dad to bring it some food
home there's a lot of thought that went
into this pictures you can see very well
done heavy and then on the side on the
left all your your right is sends those
beautiful drawing I don't know what he's
doing here he should be an artist
because he drew that in about two
seconds literally I took my eyes off all
of him and next minute there was this
beautiful bird that's picking seeds
which you it wasn't a Turtledove i think
it looks more like a turtle dove than an
African green pigeon so since on the
next page is gonna have to draw an
African green pigeon and a fig tree
eating fruits because that's what they
absolutely love to eat but there we know
her quite nice much better than my
pathetic drawing and anyways via was
talking about imagine we had giant
drongos at eight elephants so I thought
well where is it I'm looking that'll be
the day you see the shadow come over the
top of you and sweep up and take an
elephant goodness an Indian parrot okay
Rina so we were obviously looking at
Sammy's picture the green bird which we
saw earlier that I showed you on my
phone and thank you for getting back to
us was an Indian green parrot beautiful
I've never seen one before
but now I can say that I have seen one
which is pretty epic
alright well this the day is filled with
surprises isn't it brained mentioned
male-line well he's got one
well this is not what we used to seeing
when you expect to see a male line you
can see he is literally skin and bones
one of the magical ants he doesn't have
much time left I'm afraid he's desperate
for meal looks like he's also got some
TB and some growth is coming off him but
at his age
it's impressive I mean I'm not 100% sure
maybe someone can tell me how old the
magenta lands are but he's losing
condition very quickly at the moment as
I said if you are sensitive this might
not be the best lion sighting for you
but that is what happens out in the bush
this is what happens to male lions if
they don't get killed outright in the
fight there they just slowly but surely
keep losing condition shame poor old man
you know it is quite difficult to see
sometimes but you got to remember you've
got to take the beauty with the ghastly
our chair and hopefully well understate
you even know the hyenas might even
catch up with him but it's very very
seldom that an animal will die from old
edge and will normally get killed by
something else when they lose condition
like this here we go Angela thank you
very much and just as it thinks he's 14
that is incredibly old there very few
lines that will make it to 14 years old
okay and that's him gone he's headed off
and out about our traversing area okay
well it's it's difficult to see but it's
something you need to see as well can't
always be all the nice things are we
gonna do a little loop see if we can
find shadaloo maybe end up with a nice
healthy kitty
now the rest of his coalition as far as
I know are still in the far western sabi
sands I'm not sure if they I know
they're not in the best condition but
they're not not as bad as he is he seems
to be the worst out of them I think
therefore in total I I'm not sure they
used to sometimes come up into the north
western parts outside of our Traverse to
the west of Arethusa
but but they're they haven't they
haven't been for a while to see of the
Birmingham's and stuff there they're not
there haven't been in good Nick and
their old lines they're properly old
Lyons
when Mel Lyons gets that stage you have
to be quite careful around them
especially if they start hanging around
lodges because they can be a threat to
two people because he's so hungry so
desperate that's the type of lion that
is a great candidate for a maneater
those animals that unable to catch by
floo or other animals
not much of a sunset with all the clouds
okay we're gonna keep checking about and
heading for the area where we think she
didn't like that it might be let's go
ahead back to tailor who's prancing
around quarantine well we are finally
back up and on the planes of quarantine
not too far away from a camp which is
quite cool and it's got dark very
quickly like we suspected with a cloud
cover coming in the wind is dying down
well we get one last bit of rain before
dry season comes about I really hope so
I hope we get a spectacular storm
tonight I hope there's thunder and
lightning and flash floods and all these
amazing things we haven't seen floods
for quite some time so it would be nice
to have them on the reserve and I can
obviously make driving a little bit
difficult then I think that well the
sabi sand needs it after the tough few
years that's gone through with a lack of
rain so the ground I don't think it'll
be actually be too bad because we've had
enough rain that there's a lot of
vegetation covering the what's once
we're bare patches all the grass has
sprouted up all the trees look healthy
you've got lots of leaves on them a
couple of them will be losing those
leaves now as we go into winter though
so I don't think it'll be too much
erosion obviously along dams and things
like that where there's man-made dam
walls they're going to suffer but say
nothing that can't be repaired which
would be quite cool so sadly we didn't
get a view of our wildebeest friend he's
terrified today as as are the impala
they're a little bit nervous
ah look what I've just found one of my
favorite things in the whole wide world
white button sage will not this one
specifically but just sages in general
are very nice and seen as though all the
waters of it yaki at the moment with
algae and all the Buffalo and things
wallowing around in it this is what some
people would do up in Namibia take this
take a lot of them actually put them in
an ostrich egg with water and actually
help as an antibacterial so help keep
the water nice and clean pretty sure the
Egyptians used to do something along the
lines as well anyways we're going to hit
who knows the lighters fader does not
say for us to be out and walk anymore or
if you go to Steve who's at levels up
damn with the Lions yes thanks very much
Taylor I hope you both or you all get
back safely we are still with them
goomahs they are also all very
interested in what these hippos are
doing the hippos have been going up and
down in the dam probably trying to think
of a good way to get out without having
to go past a lion or two let's get into
their time of night and they also want
to get out and go and start feeding and
it looks like the Lions are going to
start going around the dam towards our
left seems to be the general sort of way
of things at the moment so we might need
to start up soon and move in that
direction because the lionesses are the
ones who lead the way here's some water
thick knees blacksmith lapwings calling
the wind has changed is coming out from
the south those clouds are still in the
sky but there seem to be very far away
at the moment so I think the storm and
rumor has abated or the potential for
the storm
very cool breeze they're coming in now
going to be a wonderful evening we one
of the cooler evening as we've had so
far this year this definitely shows that
winter is on its way we will soon be
wearing warm jackets my dart print will
be wearing a sugar
so you wonder what's going on in the
mind of those lions there looking at
this huge thing and they're probably
trying to think of different ways it
would taste hmm all very interested in
the hippo and what if any of them have
ever eaten hippo before I don't think
they've got a chance against any of
these three hippos in the dam here just
not enough weights behind them that
sighting that I saw years ago that was
recorded was actually the Lions all
jumps on the back of the hippo and the
hippo is turning left and right trying
to evade them but none of them were
really brave enough to go near the front
end which is the danger end in the hippo
and eventually it turned in a grabbed
one lioness on the face when a lioness
weighs 140 kilograms so it's close to
300 pounds plus - and it threw her away
like a rag doll and the rest of the
lines decided very quickly after that
that that was a meal they didn't feel
the need to pursue but it always amazes
me the resilience of these lines that
female survives although she lost the
use of her one eye as you can see
there's a general movement to go around
that way so I'm going to make a move see
if we can get around that side we've got
a bit of work to do if we want to follow
them that side
we can manage
marvelous afternoon sitting at purple so
exam always always a beautiful place to
sit okay so let's see if we can get
around here I know that the dam does
continue on over here they are some
lions and that wasn't so hard I thought
that was going to be harder than it was
the dam has actually filled up a bit
this is this whole section of front of
us was was drier last time I was down
here well relatively relatively shallow
sorry about the angle there Craig oh and
isn't that a beautiful silhouette and
the Lions drinking
favorite part it is very pretty ladies
gentlemen and this is my favorite part
is watching the Lions get up and start
moving and the youngsters will start
playing and it just gets all very
exciting you know they're on a road trip
now who knows what the night is going to
show them anything that come across will
move off and the wind is coming directly
into us at the moment yeah we're going
to put on eye on our infrared now folks
as the Lions all start lying down in
front of the car there's a little
glimpse at a hair in that few over sorry
about my head
we are now on infrared here we are with
the Lions one two more still coming up
from the back if that one is playing
with the stick in the water not quite
sure what it is so they are crossing
exactly where I hope they might I hope
we're going to be able to cross over
there and that the general trajectory we
cannot pay attention to that because if
they do go south that will be marvelous
I'll go straight back into the heart of
Juma but if they do keep going east and
we could lose them too quickly to
torture it cheater cut line oh it got a
fright the branch moved wasn't expecting
that
okay now that one that's an adult wants
to have a look at whatever that stick is
ten earthen hippos will most likely stay
in the water until the Lions leave I've
seen that as well with us if we spend
time at the water they will often stay
in the water until we've left only
coming out once all activity is gone
they're very shy and they don't like
their appearance because it's moving
they think it's alive okay so she does
this last line moves off will follow him
around you can see how they're just
skirting around the dam there and
they're heading in a perfectly safe wood
direction which is exactly what we want
Claire the IRS on because I'm losing
sight of them with my naked eye there
you go off we go hey folks so bear with
us as we try and navigate the swampland
ahead money joking it's not gonna be
that bad but it could be because of the
rain we've had first you've got to get
over a biggie so Craig a cuz of the rain
we had the dam potentially has filled up
a little bit more on the side here and
it's a little bit bumpy so hold on we'll
just stay here with him shall we not yet
very interested in the hippos these are
mainly the youngsters that are staying
back here
the adults are ready a little bit up
ahead youngsters want to stay and see
you at hippo tastes like they're not
quite sure why they're moving off from
something that seems to be so close by
it's for your own best interests
youngsters you do not want to be
tackling a hippo I promise you won't
know what to do with it fantastic so
from lion's mobile in the darkness let's
go to Taylor who's got some bright
lights in the tent or do we do we've
come to the tent unfortunately branches
not well this evening and so he's come
home so we wish you a speedy recovery
and I'm sure he'll be back maybe
tomorrow maybe the next day we'll let
him take as much time as he needs now we
are in the chains I haven't got anything
set up for you right now I'm waiting for
Conrad to come and sort the internet art
cuz I'd like to have a look on one of
the maps to see how big the storm is
that is moving from off the coast of
Mozambique and if we can even see it
which would be quite cool and so in the
meantime I don't know what we going to
do I was actually trying to find the
darkling beetles and things like that
but I'm going to try and find for them
and find them at some point and Carl
it's dark because the Sun has gone down
I suppose and we are in autumn at the
moment and the days are going to get
well listen
well nights are going to get darker and
arrival yeah I suppose what I'm trying
to say so that's going to happen and
it's a couple of minutes every single
night that's not what I'm looking for
where are these beetles I was actually
looking at them today there was
somewhere around here strips I think
it's a bit dark to find any insects
outside that will be active and this
something like and and flying our
lacewing wants to come on in and we were
there I don't know where they are
it's like a whole section about them
it's quite cool
oh here's the bee flies we're looking at
we're looking at this one today number
two you want to have a look
it does not got a common name oh I can
just starting to hyenas outside as well
so that's the little looks like the bee
fly that we were looking at which is
pretty cool to see I'm not even going to
try and say that that name you can read
it if you like that one over there very
very cool in fact because I said it was
a little bit cooler I was at an artist
said oh really know because her sons
will get it eventually
Rebecca also said she has no idea how
does how to say it we've seen we've also
seen this one though we've definitely
seen number one which is also a type of
bee flower actually see them flying
around quite often I'd imagine you'd
mistaken that for like a bumblebee or
something but it's much smaller very
very tiny only a couple of millimeters I
think they're all around 20 millimetres
or two centimetres or something along
those lines new to them for these let me
try and find the darkling beetles and
whereabouts they are they're being the
Kaali Opera section somewhere along the
lines but it's quite a diverse said well
family we need to get through but off to
Steve he's got lions and I'm sure he's
trying to keep up with them yes with
lions and this little youngster here is
very interested in the moving wheel
ahead to let's give it a little we're at
a moment ago cuz
I are it's got some lights on so you can
see them as the IR is on as well but
they are moving directly across the
windows I sort of anticipated you see
the wind is coming from this direction
to our right to my right-hand side here
and so they'll walk across the wind try
and pick up on the smell of any animal
in this direction and then they'll move
in that direction to try and hunt that
is the general gist of it it can take
all night ladies gentlemen
it can happen really quickly or it can
it can take all night and be no success
but that is the general sort of way of
things that I've seen in my experience
with lions and it's so nice to be
following them on the road but they are
heading in a general east direction on
hippo pools Road which is right up in
the north eastern corner towards cheetah
cut line and it's quite some time until
we get to the compliant but hopefully
they will turn in before them
child of the universe sub-adults I
haven't seen him hunt but at the age
that they're at they're more of a
hindrance when it comes to hunting then
there are an asset so they will do a lot
of the feeding a lot of the fighting but
they're they're not very important in
the hunting at the moment they basically
just follow at the back truck
quite often what you'll see is the
youngsters will end up playing at the
back while the adults are hunting and
then the meal disappears and the adults
will look back with this look of like
excuse me and then eventually when they
get hungry enough they're stopped
playing and they pay more attention but
in a pride of this size five lioness do
very very very well okay well looks like
Taylor's been this go back to her
people's well which still trying to have
a look I can't find it I found call you
up to adjust page 186 but if for some
bizarre reason where is it and then the
numbers at the bottom I can't find the
darkling beetles and I don't know why I
definitely didn't tear the pages are
today that's for sure no I say the Kali
uptrend order is quite large in many
different types of beetles from ground
beetles and something sticking around
and if it's a spider web or if it's my
hair I think was my hair particularly my
face whirling beetles parasitic cone
beetles what is a parasitic own little
this thing that's quite cool look at
that that's really impressive look at
the antennae on that I've never seen
anything like that in my entire life
ever and they seem to occur along the
coast I'm just having a quick read about
them parasitic comb beetles well maybe
they'll come here maybe we'll get them
here and what does it say about them
I've never even seen that but Bobby live
in the soil and parasitize the larvae of
cicadas oh that's quite interesting
very nice narrow attracted to lights
that is great information
it's almost people's we have to keep an
eye out for those surely we're going to
get them now
surely now as we look through all these
things I'm trying to make sure that I
find these these beetles for you so we
can try and figure out which one we had
this afternoon I'm Jamie yes I think
there's a shortage of bees throughout
the world I unfortunately think all the
different bee species are under threat
at the moment and I'm big one of course
is habitat loss as it is for most of the
decline in in animal species and
poisoning you know using pesticides and
things on plants I think would be
another one and so so yes definitely so
I'm not actually sure how many African
bees are actually left the internet is
not working so I can't even ask the
Google machine to help us which is
normally super handy but pursueth we can
get it in a moment ok darkling beetles
here we go yay I don't think that we
were looking at a docking beetle maybe
let's see yeah no that doesn't look like
any of the ones that we had today I was
did not have particularly long about
that one one no that doesn't occur yet
so it can't be that one we will try and
check weevils next that'll be the next
thing to try and find is the weevil
Paige and evils no ok so it wasn't a
darkling beetle my next bet is that it's
probably one of the weevils but we'll
make that another mission because I
think that's going to be a lot of paging
through so I'll do that when we're all
fair again what else are we going to
look what are we going to look at
I'm trying to think you know we will
have a look at just now as the inside of
a porcupine call that I broke the other
night we didn't actually get to look at
it under the microscope so we'll get
that all set up and also then try and
pay find the page on weevils but off you
go to Steve he's still doing a sterling
job they're keeping up with the cats yes
we're still with him haven't gone very
far they've been walking and told you
since you last saw us and now they're
lying down again with a sneezing there's
one coming up from the back behind us
now I can hear it
there it is that definitely
interested in something there's
definitely food on the brain but the
wind is swirling it's changing direction
quite regularly now coming from the east
and from the south and this beautiful
lioness is the rear guard so they walk
there try and get the smells of things
but often the smells Kent can be a bit
swirling so they will so rely quite
heavily on their hearing who knows what
success they might have this evening
remember ladies gentlemen this is live
we have no idea what could happen around
the next corner it could certainly
stumble across a pro a breeding herd of
buffalo stumbled across anything really
as you've seen in the past we just bump
into animals and that's what's so
marvelous about the live show so what
I'm trying to do now is I'm trying to
find a live weather map because the one
I normally use is playing games it
doesn't really want to load very well so
I'm trying to see if we can get another
one let's see so now I'm doing squats
yeah look at this how do I go soo min oh
no it doesn't let me do anything
lightning Conrad was that you making
that noise no I just heard it oh you
also heard that hey I don't know what
made that sound we won't go in
investigate we'll just stay here in the
in the tent I think it may have been
Conrad I guess so anyways I can't I'm so
sorry I can't open it as well as I
wanted to this is not the method I
normally use but if you look along here
all along the east coast there's quite a
bit of cloud cover so I'm pretty sure
that's the big storm that's coming on
through and that is what I think coming
over us at the moment and that's the
fact it's sort of spreading quite nicely
they hope that we do get one last bit of
rain I think it would be really good to
the sabi sand I don't think has seen
this much rain for a very very long time
up here in the north then the other
thing that I am I have for you I haven't
even got to the weevils yet maybe that
will be what puts me to sleep tonight is
shall we have a look at the microscope
and you see van get this working mm-hmm
and why because I'm trying to do that
says on X is just taking it the okay
we're ready there we go I was told you
take my fingers oh that's so bright is
it too bright NYX we're just having a
look at I'm just trying to find the it's
my side they me
no that's brighter that is as the dark
as the light goes unfortunately it will
have to do and anyways so this is a
porcupine call snapped in half it looks
like candy floss in the center it's
weird
I would never have expected to be filled
with a substance like this I'm sure it's
just keratin I mean if we I'm just
trying to make out how I'm gonna turn
this if you obviously if you look over
here at this but you can see that
there's long sort of strings of keratin
but I don't know
this type of keratin in yeah it's so
weird it's quite porous as well but it's
tough in the same breath I know I don't
think you would normally use porous and
tough in the same guy I don't suppose
you do cuz corals and corals are like
that anyway so it's not working as well
as what I can see on my monitor once
okay and so whatever fail we'll try and
have a look at that at some point again
but it is quite cool maybe you can see
it like this that was just gonna zoom on
in turn like that pretty cool see it's
weird I'm trying to think I've
definitely seen a substance like this
before but I don't know what coke yes
that's exactly a coconut that's exactly
what it looks like
Thank You Rebecca when you open a
coconut in there quite cool
think we're failing miserably here since
we'll just call it a well just call it a
loss it's hard to focus on it and hard
for me to keep my hands still anyways so
that was that
orange is quite cool I'm going to look
for those weevils now and when you come
back to us hopefully I'll have some
weevils I might even see if I can find a
different where the map but off you go
to Steve who's now not on a road
he's bundu bashing yes we are off road
we are following these lines don't want
to lose them we have no idea where
they're going but the good news is they
are going directly south that is all I
can tell you there they are moving with
quite a bit of purpose I wouldn't say
like running purpose but they definitely
have some intention on the mind
marci the lions can see phenomenally
well we are looking using an infrared
camera there now you see how dark it is
they can basically see what you see with
that lens that's kind of what they're
able to see if Craig goes back onto the
infrared and it goes back to the lines
are that's kind of what the Lions can
see but we're gonna see if we can keep
up with them here don't want to lose
them for you it is inevitable though but
I would like to try a little bit harder
as it starts getting quite thick the
bush but they can see very very well at
night all the Predators can they see
black and white they don't see the color
or depth that we see what enables him to
see very well in the darkness vanish
that was a branch
this is a very thick block layer
sediment I can just see the back the
backside of one there's another one
there just up ahead here I'm not going
to crouch in on them you don't want to
to disturb whatever it is that they're
doing okay fantastic let's go back over
to Taylor we'd like to show you the bird
drawings well I'm having a little scroll
through Twitter which I don't normally
do there's some great ones there we go
have a look at this one from Kim that's
beautiful
a green macaw from South America that's
beautiful goodness and who do that that
Sydney Sydney drew that choose any seven
years old very cool okay well there's
one I did see my fake can I'll show you
my favorite one is this one by Mia
Santos is this bird is very far away it
is indeed it's Carden of what you just
see when you look at birds flying
towards the sunset and who else have we
got yeah
oh he's gonna Hey look at this one this
is amazing well Katie Wow you've outdone
yourself
that's incredible of a lilac breasted
roller I think that those are the kinds
of birds I see in my dream very nice so
well done to all of you and and it was
well great to have you all join us and
and participate in draw bird David I
think what I am going to be doing now is
sending you off to watch something
that's not alive but we've taken the
time to put it together for you well for
well-thought draw a bird day
we've been celebrating draw birthday for
two years now and while it's a fun task
this small action has a very big effect
once upon a time in 1943 to be exact
Dorie Cooper a little girl of just seven
years went to visit her uncle in
hospital he had lost his leg fighting in
the Second World War
Dory's uncle was in a lot of pain
the little girl wanted to cheer him up
and so she asked uncle Rufus would you
draw a bird for me please
although he was still very weak uncle
Rufus agreed to this request from his
young niece all right Dori I'll see what
I can do he replied opening his eyes he
looked out of his window and what did he
see a beautiful Robin and so Dory's
uncle got to drawing the Robin Dori took
one look at the picture and oh how she
laughed uncle Rufus this isn't very good
but I loved it all the same it makes me
happy
Dori took this terribly drawn picture
and hung it in her room at home this
lifted her uncle's spirits he saw the
goodness in her honesty soon after that
the other wounded soldiers in the
hospital started the bird drawing
contest presently the entire Ward was
covered in bird drawings of all kinds
bad colorful artistic funny and precise
it was a sight to behold
tragically just three years later Dori
was killed in a car accident at a
funeral the coffin was filled with bird
images created by the wounded soldiers
nurses and doctors from the wall to
Edoras Uncle Henry covered every year
after that those men and women remember
that little girl who brought joy to
injured soldiers by drawing birds on her
birth
April the 8th so this 8th of April
commit your favorite feathered friend to
paper and remember that sometimes the
smallest and simplest things have the
greatest effect
you're back with us I'd like to thank
all of you out there for your wonderful
drawings and pictures I believe they are
incredible I haven't seen them it but I
will make sure I get a look when I get
back to camp we are still with the uncle
boomers and they just stopped to drink
and a little puddle but I'm hoping not
to get stuck in little mud wallow
and incredible how quickly these cats
can just disappear there they are
they're following very nice game path
hitting in a perfectly suddenly
direction
mr. game path that who actually had the
last time if you're watching with me
everywhere that a buffalo for those
Buffalo to come through this is the game
path that they actually came through run
but what a marvelous afternoon we have
had ting Ghana doing his thing lions
doing their thing Oh little clawing
scratching on the tree and the uncle
homers showing us some care and some
love this the first time of being able
to follow them spin marvelous and thanks
for being out with me this afternoon
Krieger and laser general thanks for all
your questions and comments it's been a
very nice afternoon as we try and keep
up with these very elusive cats thank
you from myself Craig and everyone else
in FC as we try to get one more little
picture of these lines as they disappear
they seem to be gone thank you so much
for joining us and we'll see you
tomorrow morning brat